This is Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vedantam. In the classic TV series Star Trek, Mr. Spock has a full-proof technique for accurately reading the thoughts and feelings of others. The Vulcan Mind Men. Through our James, Kirk, our minds are moving closer, closer, closer, closer, James Kirk, closer. Here on Planet Earth, we have no technology that gives us direct access to the minds of others. So we look for psychological clues. We watch people's facial expressions to see how much they like us.
这里是 Hidden Brain，我是香卡·维丹塔姆。在经典电视剧《星际迷航》中，史巴克先生拥有一项万无一失的技术，能够准确读取他人的思想和感受。瓦肯人的心灵感应。通过我们的詹姆斯·柯克，我们的心灵正在靠近，靠近，靠近，靠近，詹姆斯·柯克，靠近。在地球上，我们没有任何能够直接进入他人内心的技术。因此，我们要寻找心理线索。我们观察人们的面部表情，以了解他们有多喜欢我们。
We read their body language to figure out when they are nervous. We listen to their intonations to pick up signals about their mood. How accurate are these clues? How good are we at detecting what's going on in the minds of others? In recent years, scientists have spent a lot of time answering these questions. They've discovered that many of the clues we use to read the minds of others are suspect. But they have identified one mind-reading technique that is surprisingly effective. The only problem? Most of us don't use it. How to get inside someone else's head this week on Hidden Brain.
我们通过他们的肢体语言来判断他们何时感到紧张。我们倾听他们的语调来捕捉有关他们情绪的信号。这些线索有多准确？我们检测他人内心活动的能力有多强？近年来，科学家们花了很多时间来回答这些问题。他们发现，我们用来解读他人内心的许多线索都值得怀疑。但他们发现了一种令人惊讶地有效的读心术。唯一的缺点呢？我们大多数人都不使用它。本周的 Hidden Brain 将探讨如何走进别人的内心。
Navigating social life involves continually reading the minds of other people. What could be the meaning behind my colleague's behavior? What could my daughter be thinking and feeling? What is it my parents really want? Tessa West is a psychologist at New York University. She studies interpersonal accuracy. How well the attributions we make about others matches the reality of what is actually going on inside their minds. Tessa West, welcome to Hidden Brain. Thank you so much for having me.
社交生活的核心在于不断地解读他人的内心。我同事行为背后的含义是什么？我女儿可能在想什么、感受到什么？我父母真正想要的是什么？苔莎·韦斯特是纽约大学的心理学家。她研究人际准确性。我们对他人做出的归因与他们内心实际情况的契合程度如何。苔莎·韦斯特，欢迎来到 Hidden Brain。非常感谢邀请我来。
Tessa, during your undergraduate years, I understand you had a part-time job that turned out to be an excellent venue for reading other people's minds and intentions. What was this job? So the job I had was selling high-end men's shoes. It was commission-based, so every pair of shoes I sold, I got about 8% back. And really, my income was primarily determined by selling rich people very expensive shoes. And hoping I sold enough of those shoes to be able to make money for tuition. So I understand the sales team was often eager to find the customers who look like they would be the most lucrative customers given that your income
苔莎，据我了解，在你的本科期间，你曾做过一份兼职工作，事实证明，这是一个洞察他人心理和意图的绝佳场所。这是一份什么工作？我当时的工作是销售高端男鞋。这份工作是有提成的，我卖出的每一双鞋，大概能拿到8%的回报。说实话，我的收入主要取决于把昂贵的鞋子卖给有钱人。并且希望我能卖出足够多的鞋子来赚取学费。所以我理解，销售团队往往急于寻找那些看起来最有钱的客户，因为你的收入部分取决于这些提成。
depended partly on these commissions. Absolutely. The sales team developed all these clever strategies of figuring out who they could approach, who would buy the most expensive shoes, and who was also the least likely to have buyers remorse and want to return those shoes later.
当然。销售团队开发了各种聪明的策略，来弄清楚他们可以接近谁，谁会买最贵的鞋子，以及谁最不可能在购买后感到后悔并想要退货。
So, they would pay attention to things like what people were wearing, how comfortable they seemed in an expensive store, what their mannerisms were, even things like how much of an hurry they came across, all these pieces of information were used to try to figure out who the optimal customer would be. When someone promising walked into the store, Tessa's colleagues on the sales team would race to snag the customer. We called them shoe sharks, and these are the people who would immediately make a beeline for the best customers.
因此，他们会关注人们穿什么、在昂贵商店里显得多么自在、他们的举止，甚至包括他们表现得多么匆忙等细节，所有这些信息都被用来试图找出谁是最佳客户。当有很有潜力的客户走进店里时，苔莎在销售团队的同事就会争先恐后地去抢这个客户。我们称他们为“鞋子鲨鱼”，这些人会立刻径直走向最好的客户。
You know, it was a very competitive hierarchical world selling shoes, and I think you sort of had to learn how to spot that customer and grab them before anybody else could, even saying high and making eye contact, kind of count it is, this person is now my territory, they're my customer, you better not come close. So as you were finding your feet and sails, one time a customer came in wearing a three-piece suit with a poodle trailing behind him. I'm guessing this customer sounded promising. This customer was probably the most promising person I had encountered yet. He had a fancy pocket square and he showed up with this poodle that was so well groomed. You know, I could tell its haircut
你知道的，卖鞋是一个竞争非常激烈且等级森严的世界，我觉得你必须学会如何发现那个客户并在其他人之前抓住他们，甚至说“你好”并进行眼神交流，这就好比在宣告：这个人现在是我的地盘，他是我的客户，你最好离远点。所以，当你刚在销售上站稳脚跟时，有一次，一个顾客走了进来，穿着一件三件套西装，后面还跟着一只贵宾犬。我猜这个顾客听起来很有前途。这个顾客可能是我遇到过最有前途的人了。他有一块精致的口袋方巾，而且他带的那只贵宾犬修剪得非常完美。你知道的，我能看出它的发型比我的发型贵得多，而且它体型巨大。你知道的，我还是个大学生。我没钱。他带了一只巨型贵宾犬。当时，店里有一项规定，你可以带小型玩具贵宾犬，但不能带巨型贵宾犬。所以，带着一只巨型狗出现需要真正的勇气，他带着全世界所有的虚张声势大摇大摆地走进来，立刻挑出了20双他想试穿的最贵的鞋子。所以我心里想，太好了，
cost more than my haircut and it was huge. You know, I'm a college student. I have no money. He brings this giant poodle at the time. The store had a policy that you could bring your little toy poodle, but not a giant poodle. So it took some real gumption to show up with a giant dog and he kind of strolls in all the bravado in the world and immediately picks out 20 of the most expensive pairs of shoes that he wants to try on. So I'm thinking to myself, yes, I'm
仅靠这一个顾客，我就能赚到一整周所需的全部鞋子的钱了。后来怎么样了，苔莎？所以基本上发生的事情是，他挑好了鞋子。他立刻摆出了一种高高在上的姿态。这超级屈辱，但他实际上要求我单膝跪地，让他的狗给我一个吻，而我照做了，心里想着，
going to sell all the shoes that I need for this entire week just with this one customer. What happened, Tessa? So basically what happened was he picks out his shoes. He immediately kind of embraces this high status demeanor. This is super humiliating, but he actually asked me to get down on my knees and allow his dog to give me a kiss, which I did, thinking to myself,
好吧，这是钱，钱，我需要它。然后他试穿了所有这些昂贵的鞋子，还让我用鞋拔子帮他把脚穿进每一只鞋里，甚至帮他系鞋带。我的意思是，我和他在一起好几个小时。结果到头来，他什么都没买。所以他其实只是为了秀一把，就像是一场权力的游戏，来炫耀自己有多牛，
OK, this is money, money, I need it. And then he tried on all these expensive shoes and he had me use a shoe horn and put his foot in each shoe, even tie the laces for him. I mean, I was with him for several hours. At the end of the day, he bought nothing. So he was really just there, is like a power play, to really show off how great he was,
但他对买东西根本不感兴趣。所以我的意思是，显然，这家伙听起来像个十足的混蛋，但从你的角度来看，就你能否洞察别人的内心而言，这是一次学习的经历吗？是的，我的意思是，我认为我学到的是，有时我们赖以依靠的东西——比如某人的衣服有多华丽，你知道的，他们看起来有多自信——其实并不是准确解读某人意图的最佳信息。或者也许我只是试图解读错误的意图。他想要的是大量的女性关注。他不想买昂贵的鞋子。所以
but he wasn't interested in purchasing anything. So I mean, obviously, this guy sounds like a real jerk, but from your point of view, was a learning experience in terms of how well you could pick up what was happening in someone else's mind? Yeah, I mean, I think I learned that sometimes the thing we rely on, how fancy someone's clothes are, you know, how confident they appear, aren't actually the best pieces of information to accurately read someone's intentions. Or maybe I was just trying to read the wrong intentions. What he wanted was lots of female attention. What he didn't want was expensive shoes. And
那一天我真的学到了一课。另一次，一个顾客穿着汗流浃背、肮脏的衣服进来，身上沾满了泥。我猜这不是销售团队会争抢的客户。是的，这家伙进来了，穿着运动服，浑身是泥，我朝这家伙走去，他很匆忙，非常慌乱，他说，你知道的，我需要五双你们最舒适的鞋子，你知道的，给我手下的园丁穿。所以我拿出了这些鞋子，虽然很难看但很贵，然后向他推荐了这些鞋子，你知道的，给我手下的园丁穿。所以我拿出了这些鞋子，虽然很难看，但很贵，然后向他推荐了这些鞋子。
so I really learned a lesson that day. Another time a customer comes in wearing a sweaty, dirty clothes he's covered in mud. I'm guessing that this is not a customer that the sales team fights over. Yeah, this guy comes in, he's wearing sweats, he's got dirt all over him, and I walk up to this guy, and he's in a hurry, he's very flustered, and he says, you know, I need five pairs of your most comfortable shoes, you know, for my gardeners. So I pull up these shoes that are ugly but expensive and offer him these shoes, you know, for my gardeners. So I pull up these shoes that are ugly, but expensive, and offer him these shoes.
他说，好吧，只要三种不同尺码的就行。我现在急需。我住在蒙特西托，就有点像奥普拉住的那种地方。那是圣巴巴拉一个非常昂贵的地方。你知道的，我的园丁脚上都磨出了水泡。我今天甚至不得不自己割草，你知道的，这太糟糕了。我需要你立刻帮我解决问题。
And he says, OK, just get them in three different sizes. I'm desperate right now. I live in Monacito, which is like where Oprah lives. It's a very expensive part of Santa Barbara. You know, my gardeners have blisters. And I had to actually mow my own lawn today, you know, a terrific thing. I need you to fix my problem right away.
于是他立刻买了几千美元的鞋子。我学到了另一课。在判断别人的意图时，你不能总是依赖他们的穿着。而我在那里算是阴差阳错地做对了。但是，你知道的，这对我也说也是一次非常重要的学习经历。所以你大学毕业了，拿到了博士学位，最终你进入了就业市场，有一次你被邀请去纽约大学（NYU）面试，有人告诉你，如果你在面试时戴眼镜，他们会更严肃地对待你。
And so immediately he buys, you know, thousands of dollars worth of shoes. And I learned another lesson. You cannot always rely on what people are wearing in judging their intentions. And there I was sort of lucky to be wrong. But, you know, that was also a very important learning experience for me. So you finish college, you get your PhD and eventually you go on the job market and at one point you're invited for an interview at New York University NYU and someone told you that if you wore glasses for the interview that they would take you more seriously.
你为什么会得到这样的建议，苔莎？是的，没错。所以我想很多人都认为，当你是一个年轻女性时——我当时25、26岁——你需要让自己看起来更聪明、更专业，而人们用来判断这一点的信息之一就是你是否戴了眼镜。
Why did you get this advice, Tessa? Yeah, that's right. So I think a lot of people assume that when you're a young woman, I was 25, 26 at the time, that you need to make yourself look smarter, more professional, and one piece of information people use to judge that is whether you're wearing glasses.
所以我接受了这个建议。我平时其实戴隐形眼镜，但我特意出去买了一些眼镜，其实我都度数不合适。我摘下隐形眼镜，戴着眼镜去参加面试，希望能起作用。我还穿了一些别人告诉我的衣服，
So I took this advice. I actually normally wear contacts, but I went out, I bought some glasses, and I couldn't actually forward. I took my contacts out, I wore the glasses on the interview, hoping that that would work. I also wore some outfits that other people had told me
这些衣服会让我看起来不那么年轻、不那么稚气，所有这些都是为了打破刻板印象。所以我真的全力以赴地接受了这个建议，因为那是一个人关于什么真正管用的朴素理论。所以你到了面试现场，你说话时眼镜一直在鼻子上往下滑。什么，能跟我讲讲面试是怎么进行的吗？
would make me look less young, less girly, all these kinds of things to kind of counter-stereotypes. And so I really went in and leaned into that advice because that was what one person's lay theory was of what actually works. So you get to this interview, your glasses are sliding down your nose as you talk. What, walk me through how the interview played out?
你知道的，面试非常艰难。所以我在那里，做着展示，我有PPT，戴着让我不舒服的眼镜，不到一分钟就有人举手，他们有点质疑我的整个研究项目。在接下来大约一个半小时里，那些手就不停地举起来。你这话是什么意思？
You know, the interview was very tough. So I'm up there, I'm giving this presentation, I have a PowerPoint, I'm in my uncomfortable glasses, and within a minute someone raises their hand, they kind of question my whole program of work. And for the next hour and a half or so, just constantly, those hands are popping up. What did you mean by this?
你是怎么操纵这个的？我真的觉得大家一定很讨厌我。这太艰难了。我以前不习惯这样。我不是来自一个人们充满攻击性的地方。我来自一个友好的文化背景，人们在最后提问，并且他们总是以……开头。
How did you manipulate this? I really felt like people must hate me. This is very rough. I was not used to that. I didn't come from a place where people are aggressive. I came from a sort of nice culture where people ask questions at the end and they always led with, you know,
这是一项很棒的研究，关于这个额外的方面你有什么看法？而这次完全不同。我听说当你那天晚上回到酒店时，你发现裤子的一条接缝裂开了。是的，这简直是雪上加霜。哦，天哪，我现在又在重温这次面试了。我的裤子彻底撕裂了。所以除了纳闷“别人对我的研究有什么看法？”之外，你还得承受：哦，天哪，他们不仅在挑剔他们显然讨厌我的研究，而且他们可能还看到了我压根不想露出的太多皮肤。
this is wonderful research, how about this one additional thing, and this was very different. I understand when you got back to your hotel that night, you saw that there was a seam in your pants to the head come undone. Yeah, just to add insult to injury. Oh wow, now I'm reliving this interview. My pants were completely ripped. So on top of wondering, what did people think of my research? You layer onto this. Oh my gosh, they were not only thinking of my research that they clearly hated, but they could probably also see way too much skin that I had no intention of showing.
直到今天，我实际上都不敢看我面试的录像，因为我害怕看到自己离开镜头时的样子。几天后，苔莎的一位导师认为他在一次会议上从纽约大学搜寻委员会成员那里打听到了一些情报。所以我在这次会议后遇到了我的导师，我走进他的办公室，他的脸拉得很长，显得很悲伤。他问，发生了什么？他说，我觉得你进不了纽约大学了。
To this day, I actually won't watch the videotape of my interview because I'm horrified of what I will see when I walk away from the camera. Some days later, one of Tessa's mentors thought he picked up some intel from an NYU search committee member at a conference. So I run into my mentor after this conference and I walk into his office and his face is just long and sad. And he said, what happened? He goes, I don't think you're getting the NYU job.
我的心开始狂跳。我说，发生什么了？他们跟你说我很差劲吗？我早就知道。我早就知道他们觉得我很差劲。他说，没有。我在大厅对面看到了搜寻委员会的一名成员。
And my heart starts pounding. And I said, what happened? Did they tell you I was bad? I knew it. I knew they thought I was bad. He said, no. I saw one of the search committee members across the hall.
他和我进行了眼神交流。然后他径直朝卫生间走去。他不想跟我说话。因此，你没有得到这个职位。非常遗憾地通知你。所以他以为搜寻委员会的成员在躲着他，因为接下来会是一场尴尬的对话。是的。苔莎只好接受了自己没能拿到纽约大学工作的现实。她为自己认为已经结束的学术生涯感到悲伤。她开始考虑
And he made eye contact with me. And then he made a b-line for the bathroom. He didn't want to talk to me. Therefore, you did not get this position. I'm really sorry to tell you. So he thought the search committee member was avoiding him because it was going to be an awkward conversation. Yep. Tessa resigned herself to the reality that she had lost out on the NYU job. She grieved what she thought was the end of her academic career. She started to think about
去烹饪学校。然后，几个月后，她接到了纽约大学搜寻委员会负责人的电话。他说，恭喜你，你知道的，我是来向你提供这个职位的。我当时惊呆了，我说，你打错人了吧？他就像是，这是苔莎·韦斯特吗？是的，我是苔莎。你确定是要把工作给我吗？他说，当然，就是你。然后我说，好的，我接受。而他却说，不，不，不，不，不。
going to cooking school. Then Then a couple of months later, she got a call from the head of the NYU Search Committee. And he says, congratulations, you know, I'm here to offer you the position. And I was shocked and I said, are you calling the right person? And he's like, is this Tessa West? Yeah, this is Tessa. Are you sure you mean to offer me the job? And he's like, absolutely, it's you. And then I said, yes, I'll take it. And he's like, no, no, no, no, no.
我就当我没听过你这话。你得好好谈判才能拿到一个好offer，不过恭喜啦。所以我把整件事、整个流程都搞砸了。所以我把整件事、整个流程都搞砸了。所以我把整件事、整个流程都搞砸了。请注意，在流程的每一步中，读心的错误都导致了错误的结论。苔莎以为戴眼镜会让自己看起来很聪明。相反，她给人的感觉是浑身不自在。她以为严厉的质问是充满敌意的证据。其实并不是。她的导师错误解读了会议上某个正要去卫生间的成员投来的一瞥。
I'm going to pretend you didn't say that. You're going to have to negotiate to get a good offer, but congrats. So I screwed up everything, the whole process. So I screwed up everything, the whole process. So I screwed up everything, the whole process. Notice that at each step of the process, mind-reading mistakes led to faulty conclusions. Tessa assumed wearing glasses would make her look smart. Instead, she came across as uncomfortable. She figured the tough questioning was evidence of hostility. It wasn't. Her mentor mistreated glance from someone at a conference
从这一瞥中，他得出结论：纽约大学要拒绝苔莎。又猜错了。事实上，苔莎唯一一次获得关于纽约大学委员会对她真正看法的确凿证据，是委员会负责人打电话来向她提供这份工作的时候。她的反应呢？难以置信。
who was headed for the bathroom. From this glance, he concluded NYU was going to reject Tessa. Wrong again. In fact, the one time Tessa had hard evidence about what the NYU committee really thought of her was when the head of the committee called to offer her the job. Her reaction? Disbelief.
读心错误在人际关系中造成了一些最糟糕的后果。加入纽约大学一段时间后，苔莎发现自己在一次会议上与本校的一位同事交谈。所以我去参加了这个会议。地点在加利福尼亚州圣地亚哥，那里非常漂亮。我有点兴奋能享受美好的天气，但我也非常紧张，因为我是一名新晋助理教授。我觉得自己有点力不从心。我毕业的项目不像其他人毕业的那些项目那么有名。我去参加这个会议，遇到了另一位助理教授，我们聊了几分钟，然后他看着我，说：“真的很抱歉，我觉得我不能
Errors in mind reading produced some of their worst consequences in interpersonal relationships. Some time after she joined NYU, Tessa found herself talking to a colleague from her own school at a conference. So go to this conference. It's in San Diego, California, which is beautiful. I'm kind of excited to enjoy the nice weather, but I'm also very nervous because I'm a new assistant professor. I feel like I'm a little bit in and over my head. I came from a program that wasn't as prestigious as some of the other programs that people came from. And I go to this conference and I run into another assistant professor and we're chatting for a few minutes and then he looks at me and says, I'm really sorry, I don't think I can
再跟你说话了。”我在想，好吧，这太奇怪了。他说，我想我需要和不共事的人多接触。我真的需要扩大我的社交网络。所以我现在要走开去和别人谈话了。我记得当时我在想，我口臭吗？我还不够大牌吗？我还不够有身份吗？
talk to you anymore. And I'm thinking, okay, this is weird. And he says, I think I need to spend time with people who I don't work with. I really need to expand my social network. So I'm gonna walk away now and go talk to other people. And I remember thinking, is my breath gross? Am I not a big deal enough? Am I not high status enough?
所以我的脑子里转过各种各样的原因，想着这个人为什么不想再跟我说话了。为此我感到有点心碎，觉得自己是不是做了什么十恶不赦的事冒犯了这个人。所有这些负面想法都在我脑海中闪过。听起来他好像有点看不起你。
So my head is just kind of reeling with all these reasons why this person wouldn't want to talk to me anymore. And I felt a little bit heartbroken over that that maybe I've done something horribly wrong to offend this person. All of these negative thoughts are going through my mind. It almost sounds like he was looking down at you.
是的，我确实有这种感觉。我的感觉是，他是一个渴望往上爬的社交攀附者，一个为了往上爬拼尽全力、根本不在乎是否会冒犯别人的人，并且理所当然地认为这种策略是可以接受的。我内心深处甚至怀疑是不是自己做错了什么。
Yeah, I definitely felt that. What I felt was he was a thirsty social climber, someone who is just trying really hard to get ahead and didn't really care whether he's offending someone to get there and just assume that this kind of strategy was acceptable. And part of me questioned whether I was the one that was making the mistake.
也许这真的是圈内人做的事，他们会告诉别人“我不能跟你说话，我得去扩大我的社交网络”。我当时真的觉得在这个问题上彻底迷失了方向。我听说你后来发现他的反应主要源于他自己的焦虑。这与他对你的感觉或态度几乎没有什么关系。
Maybe this is actually what the people in the know do is they tell others I can't talk to you, I have to go expand my social network. I just felt like very lost for the cause there. I understand that you later discovered that his reaction was mostly about his own anxieties. They had very little to do with his feelings or attitudes towards you.
是这样吗？是的，我想他觉得这是他应该做的事。甚至都不是他非得想做的事。他其实挺聊得来的，但他觉得所有人的目光都在盯着他，其他人都在看他并心想，你知道的，为什么他要和同事说话？为什么他要试图进行社交连接，你知道的，并且对他产生各种各样的猜测？
Is that right? Yeah, I think he felt that this is what he ought to do. It wasn't even what he wanted to necessarily do. He was actually engaged in the conversation, but he felt like all eyes run him and other people were looking at him and thinking, you know, why is he talking to his colleague? Why is he trying to socially connect and, you know, inferring all kinds of things about him?
也许他反社会，或者你知道的，也许他拒绝和纽约大学以外的任何人说话。他在这一点上是个势利眼。所以所有这些想法都在他脑海里盘旋，导致他对我做出这种行为，老实说，这跟我一点关系也没有。人际关系中的许多紧张和冲突都源于对别人心里在想什么做出了不准确的归因。苔莎·韦斯特开始思考，有没有什么诀窍能让人更准确地解读别人的内心？
Maybe he's antisocial or, you know, maybe he refuses to speak to anyone outside of NYU. He's a snob about that. So all of these things were going through his mind, which led him to engage in this behavior towards me, that honestly had nothing to do with me. So many tensions and conflicts and human relationships stem from making inaccurate attributions about what is going on in other people's minds. Tessa West began to think, are they tricks to getting folks to be more accurate in reading other people's minds?
你正在收听的是 Hidden Brain，我是香卡·韦丹塔姆。这里是 Hidden Brain，我是香卡·韦丹塔姆。心理学家苔莎·韦斯特研究人际准确性，即我们衡量他人思想和感受的能力。我们已经看到，将思想和感受错误归因于他人是多么容易。当然，很长一段时间以来，我们中的许多人经常发现自己是这些错误的承受者。苔莎，你曾有过一些难忘的经历，别人把你的心思猜错了。其中一次涉及一个在你的实验室工作了三年的学生。你能跟我讲讲那个故事吗？
You're listening to Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vedantam. This is Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vedantam. Psychologist Test-o-west studies interpersonal accuracy, How well we gauge other people's thoughts and feelings. We've seen how easy it is for us to misattribute thoughts and feelings to others. Quite regularly, of course, many of us find ourselves at the receiving end of these errors. Tessa, you've had some memorable experiences of people reading your mind wrong. One of them involved a student who had been working in your lab for three years. Can you tell me that story?
是的，这个故事对我来说其实挺让人心碎的。我和一个学生共事了三年，她在我面前总是显得有点紧张。有一天，她来找我坦白，你知道的，过去几年里我一直不敢跟你说话，因为我以为你真的很讨厌我。我说，你知道的，你在说什么？你凭什么会这么想？她说，嗯，你知道的，几年前，我在电梯里看到你，你给了我一个白眼。
Yeah, this story is actually pretty heartbreaking for me. So I've been working with a student for three years and she always seemed a little bit nervous around me. And one day she comes to me and confesses, you know, for the past several years I was afraid to come talk to you because I thought you really hated me. I said, you know, what are past several years, I was afraid to come talk to you because I thought you really hated me. I said, you know, what are you talking about? Why on earth would you think that? And she said, well, you know, a couple years ago, I saw you in the elevator and you gave me the stink eye.
从那时起，我就认定你讨厌我。当然，我甚至都不记得这个电梯里的时刻了。我恰好长了一张这样的脸：如果我没有刻意微笑，我看起来总是有点烦躁、生气和恼火。我想，哦，她抓包了我顶着一张中性脸的样子。我知道是怎么回事了。
And from then on, I just decided that you disliked me. Of course, I can't even remember this elevator moment. I happen to have one of those faces where if I'm not actively smiling, I just look kind of irritable and angry and annoyed all the time. I'm like, oh, she caught me in a neutral face. I know what happened.
谁知道我当时在想什么？我可能只是在想，我现在好想喝咖啡啊。当她遇到我时，她脑子里想的全部就是这个，但这真的让我震惊，这个学生对我有了一个瞬间的判断，仅仅通过短暂的一瞥。我们说的是最多30秒。她从我脸上的表情推断出了大量的
And who knows what I was thinking? I was probably just thinking to myself, I really want coffee like so bad right now. That's all I want when she ran into me, but it really struck me that this student had a snap moment with me, a thin slice. We're talking 30 seconds max. She inferred a ton of information from the look
信息，并且在接下来的几年里，这塑造了她对我的行为方式。所以这件事促使你开始研究人际准确性，调查我们为什么会错误归因思想和感受。同样，你发现的最重要的事之一，依然是你在这里刚刚指出的这一点：我们倾向于从太少的数据外推到太大的结论。是的，我认为确实如此。
on my face and it shaped her behavior towards me for several years. So this incident spurred you to begin researching interpersonal accuracy, investigating why we miss attribute thoughts and feelings. And again, one of the most important things you found was again, what you just identified here, our tendency to extrapolate from too little data to too large conclusions. Yeah, I think that's true.
而且我认为同样重要的是，这个学生在另一种情境下看到了我。她在课堂上看到我时，我的表现力要强得多。我往往很爱开玩笑、有趣。我试着让学生参与进来。这是让讲课变得生动的一部分。而这与看到我卸下防备形成了对比。这就好比作完大型演讲或发言后走下舞台，
And I think it's also important that the students saw me in another contact. She saw me in the classroom where I'm much more performative. I tend to be very joky, fun. I try to engage the students. It's part of making a lecture come alive. And she can trust that with see me kind of let down. It's kind of like walking off stage after giving a big talk or a big speech,
在洗手间里撞见演讲者。他们的举止会与你看到他们表现出经过深思熟虑的、过度友好的行为时大不相同。我认为真正震撼她的是这两种状态之间的对比。我不认为她的经历是个例。我认为我们很多人实际上都对人们做出了不准确的判断，因为我们将他们置于截然不同的情境中进行对比。
running into the speaker in the bathroom. Their mannerisms are going to be very different than when you watch them displaying very deliberative over the top friendly behaviors. And I think what really struck her was the contrast between those two. And I don't think her experience is unique. I think a lot of us actually make inaccurate judgments of people because we're contrasting them into very different settings.
我想我们经常看到这种情况发生，当学生在课堂之外遇到他们的老师时。我的意思是，就在前几天，我和我儿子在一起，他遇到了一个戴着耳机的高地营地辅导员，那个辅导员就一直往前走，你知道的，挥了挥手说了声“嗨”然后继续走，我儿子就说：“妈妈，为什么我的辅导员不喜欢我？”我说：“他很忙，亲爱的。我知道当你玩躲避球时，他平时对你非常友好，但这
And I think we see this happen all the time when students run into their teachers outside of the classroom. I mean, just the other day, I was with my son and he ran into a camp counselor who was wearing headphones and the counselor just kind of kept walking, you know, waved and said, hi, and kept walking and he's a mommy. Why doesn't my counselor like me? I'm like, he's busy, honey. Like, I know he's normally very friendly towards you when you're playing dodgeball, but this
是不同的情境。”所以我认为，学会理解情境至关重要并提醒自己这一点，这很有道理。所以情境的另一种版本可能是我们所说的文化。当我想起你在纽约大学的那场面试时，
is a different context. So I think there is something to be said for learning that the context matters and reminding yourself of that. So another version of context is what we might call culture. And when I think about the interview that you had at NYU, part of what was happening during that interview,
面试过程中发生的一部分事情——对你来说显得极具攻击性——其实反映了纽约大学内部的文化。你能谈谈这个想法吗？包括纽约大学当时发生了什么促成了那种面试，以及文化如何影响我们解读他人内心的更广泛的观点？是的，我想是的，在纽约大学，有趣的是，我实际上把那种具有攻击性的行为解读为
which came across as very aggressive to you, was really reflective of the internal culture at NYU. Can you talk about that idea, both of what was happening at NYU that prompted that kind of interview, as well as a larger point of the ways in which culture influences how we're reading other people's minds? Yeah, I think so at NYU, what was interesting is that I actually took that behavior of aggression, and I inferred it meant
不喜欢，但事实上，在纽约大学情况恰恰相反。人们参与度越高，问的问题越多，对你的逼问越紧，他们就越觉得你聪明，对你的兴趣就越大。所以我其实关注到了正确的信息，但我却用相反的方式去解读它。你知道的，如果我早知道那种文化——即大量的问题意味着极好的事情，
dislike, and in fact, the opposite is true at NYU. The more engaged people are, the more questions they ask, the more they push you, the smarter they think you are, the more interested they are. And so I actually was attending to the right information, but I was interpreting it in the opposite way. And you know, had I had known that about the culture that lots of questions means great things.
这意味着他们觉得你很聪明，对这项研究很感兴趣——我会对那种行为做出完全不同的归因。我认为这种情况实际上经常发生。当我们进入一种不同的文化时，我们意识到自己带有某种文化偏见，可能并不完全理解这些行为的含义。
It means they think you're smart, they're interested in the work. I would have made a very different attribution for that behavior. And I think this actually can happen a lot. We walk in a different culture as we're aware that we have this cultural bias that maybe we're not totally exposed to what those behaviors mean.
我们在形成这些印象时往往会做出错误的推断，因为我们太锚定于我们自己的文化和我们自己的经验。你也研究过一种叫做“自我中心偏误”的现象。这是什么，苔莎？自我中心偏误可能是人们在努力留下准确印象时最难克服的事情之一。这就是说，我们自己脑子里发生的事情是我们拥有的最丰富的的信息源。我们会锚定我们认为别人在想什么、
And we often make incorrect inferences when we form those impressions because we're anchored so much on our own culture, on our own experiences. You've also studied the phenomenon of something called egocentric bias. What is this, Tessa? Ego-centric bias is probably one of the toughest things to get people to overcome when it comes to making accurate impressions. So this is the idea that what goes on in our own minds is the rich of source of information that we have. And we anchor what we think other people are thinking
感受到什么，并根据我们自己的经历来体验。所以，正如你在心理学会议上与同事发生糟糕互动的那个例子，你带着极大的焦虑进入那场互动。你知道的，当纽约大学说他们想雇佣你时，你怀疑他们是不是打错了电话、知不知道自己在做什么；当你到会议室时，你感觉自己并不真正属于资深学者的群体。所以在某种程度上，似乎
and feeling, experiencing based on our own experiences. So in the case of the bad interaction you had with your work colleague at the psychology conference, you came into that interaction with so many anxieties. You know, when NYU said they wanted to hire you, you questioned if they had called the right person, if they knew what they were doing, when you wanted to hire you, your question, if they had called the right person, if they knew what they were doing, when you got to the conference, you felt like you didn't really belong in a crowd of senior scholars. So in some ways, it seems
当你开始解读你同事的内心时，你可能在投射你自己的内在焦虑。当然。我绝对是在投射我自己的内在焦虑。而且我认为，特别是在情况不明、原因不清的情况下，那些模棱两可的情境是自我中心偏误的绝佳滋生地。我们不太确定某人在做什么，所以我们只会假设这是因为我们脑子里堆积的那些乱七八糟的事。我觉得那个例子有趣的地方在于，表现出那些行为的人其实也带有自我中心偏误。他做出这些举动是因为他觉得
like you may have been projecting your own internal anxieties when you started reading the mind of your colleague. Absolutely. I was definitely projecting my own internal anxieties. And I think, especially when the situation is a little bit unclear what the causes, those ambiguous situations are perfect breeding grounds for egocentric bias. We're not quite sure why someone's doing what they're doing. So we're just going to assume it's because of all this stuff going on in our own heads. And I think the funny thing about that example is the person who engaged in those behaviors was also had an egocentric bias. He was doing these things because he thought
每个人都在盯着他，而这是他应该做的。所以自我中心偏误实际上在感知者（我）和行动者/目标（那个人）之间双向起作用。有趣的研究表明，当我们认为另一个人与我们相似时，我们更有可能进行投射。但当我们认为人们与我们不同时，
everyone was staring at him and this is what he ought to do. And so the egocentric bias is actually going in both directions between the perceiver, me, and also the actor, the target, that person. There's been interesting research that shows that we are more likely to deploy projection when we see the other person as being similar to us. But when we see people as different from us,
我们往往会退而求其次，依赖另一种产生自身形式错误归因的心理错误。你能谈谈刻板印象如何成为一种错误归因形式吗？在判断他人时，刻板印象是我们依赖的最大信息来源之一，特别是如果我们对他们不了解的话。这会影响对人的知觉，
we tend to fall back on a different mental error that produces its own form of misattribution. Can you talk about how stereotypes might be a form of misattribution? Stereotypes are one of the biggest sources of information we rely on when it comes to judging other people, especially if we don't know them personally. So this influences person perception
尤其是准确性，因为这些期待就像一副眼镜，通过它我们感知并关注周围的所有信息。如果我们预期它会发生，我们就更有可能关注与这些预期一致的信息。我们会忘记那些不一致的事情，
and accuracy in particular, because these expectations just serve as a lens through which we perceive and attend to all the information around us. If we expect it to happen, we're more likely to attend to information that's consistent with those expectations. We forget the stuff that's not consistent
并且彻底将其否定。你知道的，根本不予理睬或者完全忘掉。这个问题不仅限于我们在感知上的错误。我们不断向他人发出不准确的信号，使他们更有可能产生强烈的误读。在一项研究中，苔莎发现人们不遗余力地传达与他们真实想法截然相反的信息。我们在这项研究中发现，我们把人们请来，让他们做一个谈判任务，
and we completely write it off. You know, don't pay attention to it at all or forget it completely. The problem is not limited to our errors in perception. We constantly give off inaccurate signals to other people, making it more likely, they will read a strong. to other people, making it more likely, they will read a strong. In one study, Tessa found people went out of their way to communicate the opposite of what they were really thinking. We found in this study, so we brought people in, we had them do a negotiation task, there
谈判有赢家和输家，我们让他们互相反馈对方的表现以及可以改进的地方。我们操纵了这种反馈是主动要求的还是未被要求的。我们发现，当你给没有主动要求反馈的人提供反馈时，人们实际上笑得更多，他们的表达方式很友好，尽管他们面对的往往是刚刚在谈判中输给自己的人，但他们能想到的只有对方在谈判中表现出色的地方。所以即使在建设性的反馈最合情合理的语境下，他们也会说：当你做X、Y、Z时，真是
was a winner and a loser of the negotiation, and we had them give feedback to each other on how they performed, what they could do better. And we manipulated whether that feedback was asked for or not. And what we found was when you're giving feedback to someone that they didn't ask for, people actually smiled more, they were friendly and they're delivery, and despite the fact that they're often talking to someone who just lost to them, the only thing they could come up with were great things that they did well in the negotiation. So even in context where constructive feedback makes the most sense, they're like, it was
太棒了。所以他们是在蓄意向世界传递并不反映他们真实想法的信息。这就像是为了建立亲和关系、为了与某人建立联系而进行的一种伪装。苔莎和其他研究人员还发现，权力动态决定了我们是否能准确揭示内心发生的事情。处于低权力地位的人倾向于掩盖他们的所思所想。
wonderful when you did XYZ. So they're intentionally giving information to the world that isn't reflecting what they're actually thinking. It's like this deception in an effort to create rapport, to build a relationship with someone. Tessa and other researchers have also found that power dynamic shape, whether we accurately reveal what is happening inside our minds. Low-power people tend to mask what they are thinking and feeling.
处于高权力地位的人更有可能宣泄他们的内心想法。而在感知方面，情况则会发生翻转。权力较小的人更善于解读权力较大者的心理状态。例如，孩子们往往摸透了他们父母的脾性。当然。我儿子发现，如果我正在手机上打字，这就是在亚马逊上要求购买一些宝可梦卡的最佳时机。而你知道的，如果我正在做晚饭，那就是个糟糕的时机，因为我讨厌做晚饭，而且我心情
High-power people are more likely to broadcast their internal thoughts. Things get flipped when it comes to perception. People with less power are better at reading the mind states of the powerful. Children, for example, often have their parents number. Absolutely. My son has figured out that if I'm typing on my phone is the best time to ask to purchase some Pokemon card on Amazon. And that, you know, and if I'm making dinner, it is a bad time, because I hate making dinner, and I'm in a bad
很不好。所以，是的，孩子们会学会这些，你知道的，教室里的孩子们也会学会这些。我认为当人们的成败取决于他人时，他们就会捕捉到这些线索。我们讨论过的一些例子听起来可能很幽默，但读心错误会产生严重的后果。一个觉得医生不够专注或带有敌意的黑人患者可能更不愿意透露医疗问题。一个陷入刻板印象的医生可能会漏掉重要的事情。苔莎还发现，
mood. So, yes, kids learn these things, you know, kids in classrooms learn these things. I think people pick up on these cues when they're outcome dependent upon others. Some of the examples we've discussed can sound humorous, but errors in mind reading can have serious consequences. A black patient who feels a doctor is being inattentive or hostile might be less likely to reveal a medical problem. A doctor who falls back on stereotypes can miss something important. Tessa has also found that mistakes in
解读他人内心的失误会导致团队表现变差。所以，你解读团队中人际关系的能力似乎有着某种独特和特别之处，而这种能力明显与你所在的团队表现良好、没有地位冲突、不与他人争夺地位、知道什么时候该退居幕后以及什么时候可以接管权力职位的能力息息相关。我们发现，这种“读懂房间”的能力可以预测你在创造力任务中的表现。
reading the minds of others leads to worse performance in teams. So there is something kind of unique and special about your ability to read, you to read how people are relating to one another on teams, and that ability is distinctly related to your ability and your own teams to perform well, and also to not have status conflict, to not be jockeying for status with another person, to know when it's time to step back, and when it's time that you can actually take over a position of power. And we have found that this ability to read the room predicts how well you do on a creativity
它还能预测我们所说的地位冲突。这就是人们一直在争吵的情况。我们无法弄清楚谁应该负责。到头来没有人真正赞同谁来负责、每个人的角色是什么。我认为有趣的是，你知道的，地位等级往往名声不好。
task. It also predicts what we call status conflict. So this is the idea that people were fighting the entire time. We couldn't figure out who should be in charge. No one really agreed at the end of the day who's in charge, what people's roles are. And I think what's interesting about this is, you know, status hierarchy's often get a bad reputation.
但弄清楚这些关系、很早就赋予地位，实际上对团队的成功至关重要。这就是，你知道的，“读懂房间”的能力直接关系到能够迅速结束这一过程、继续前行并很好地合作的能力。我们还发现存在“烂苹果效应”。如果你在团队中安插了一个在这方面真的很差劲的人，他们会彻底扰乱团队的进程。
But figuring those out, conferring status really early on is actually critical for group success. And this is, you know, the ability to read the room is directly related to the ability to just get that process over with, move on with things, and then work well together. And we also found that there's a bad apple effect. So if you put one person on a team who's really bad at this, they can completely disrupt the group process.
他们会打断错的人。你知道的，当重要人物在说话时他们会接话。所以，即使只有一个人不具备这种人际感知能力，也会彻底打乱和破坏团队进程。稍后回来，我们将揭晓探寻他人内心真实想法的魔术。你正在收听的是 Hidden Brain，我是香卡·韦丹塔姆。这里是 Hidden Brain。我是香卡·韦丹塔姆。苔莎·韦斯特是纽约大学的心理学家。
They're interrupting the wrong people. You know, they're taking over when someone important is saying something. And so even just one person who's bad at this kind of person perception skills can completely throw off and disrupt group processes. When we come back, the magic trick to discovering what is really going on in someone else's mind. You're listening to Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vedantam. This is Hidden Brain. I'm Shankar Vedantam. Tessa West is a psychologist at New York University.
她研究人际准确性的益处，即对其他人的行为做出正确的归因。苔莎和其他研究人员测试了各种技术，以引导人们在解读他人内心时变得更加准确。苔莎认为，人们不善于读心的原因之一可能是他们没有做好这项工作的动力。她想，为什么我们不解决这个问题呢？她向志愿者提供高达100美元的奖金，只要他们能准确猜出浪漫伴侣
She studies the benefits of interpersonal accuracy, coming up with the right attributions for other people's behavior. Tessa and other researchers have tested a variety of techniques to induce people to become more accurate as they read other people's minds. Testar figure that one reason people might be bad at reading other minds is because they're not motivated to do a good job. She thought, why don't we fix that? She offered volunteers as much as $100 to accurately guess what their romantic partners
在想什么。如果动力是问题所在，实打实的现金应该能解决这个问题。我们发现，总的来说，这并没有什么真正用处。所以这是我们真正测试“不准确性实际上是关于动力”这一想法的尝试。如果你给人们钱，你能让他们答对。有一点证据支持这一点，但没有哪个证据能让我太有信心。金钱奖励未能提高人们解读浪漫伴侣内心的准确性，这向苔莎说明了一个重要问题。缺乏动力可能并不是问题所在。所以你可以把人们放在一个没有动力去保持准确性的实验中，他们
were thinking. If motivation was the problem, cold, hard cash ought to correct the problem. We found that by and large, it doesn't really work. So this was our attempt at really testing this idea that, you know, inaccuracy is really about motivation. And if you give people money, you can get them to be right. There's a little bit of evidence to support it, but nothing that I would be too confident in. The fact that monetary incentives fail to improve people's accuracy in reading the minds of their romantic partners, told Tesla something important. A lack of motivation might not be the problem. So you can put people in an experiment where they're not motivated to be accurate, they
他们在思考。如果动机是问题所在，冷冰冰的现金应该能解决问题。我们发现，总的来说，这其实并没有用。所以这是我们真正测试这一想法的尝试，你知道，不准确确实是关于动机的。如果你给人们钱，你能让他们变得正确。有一些证据支持这一点，但没有多少证据能让我对此充满信心。金钱奖励未能提高人们解读浪漫伴侣心思的准确性这一事实，向特斯拉透露了一些重要信息。缺乏动机可能不是问题所在。所以你可以把人们放在一个他们没有动力去保持准确的实验中，他们
have no reason to care, and you can give them money and that basically just makes them pay more attention. But I think in the real world, in naturalistic interactions, we're all motivated to be accurate. We all actually care. You know, there's often a lot on the line. And so offering that incentive just doesn't really get us there. So another intervention has involved asking volunteers to engage in perspective taking, to imagine putting themselves in other people's shoes as a way of getting a better understanding of what's happening in the minds of other people. How do these experiments turn out and what do they find, Tessa?
根本不在乎，你给他们钱也只是让他们更关注一点。但在现实世界中，在自然的互动中，我们都有动机去追求准确性。其实我们都在乎。你知道，很多时候风险很大。因此，提供这种激励并不能真正达到我们的目的。所以另一种干预方法是让志愿者进行换位思考，想象自己站在别人的立场上，以此来更好地理解别人的内心在想什么。这些实验结果如何，他们发现了什么，苔丝？
You know, the shorter answer is they don't work. What they do is they actually increase your confidence in your ability to read people. And they can reduce that egocentric bias we talked about. They do not increase accuracy because they're not actually giving you any information that you can use to make judgments. And in some cases, they actually backfire. So if you're engaging in an interaction with someone from a different race, a different culture, and I tell you to perspective take, what that can do is make you feel very anxious
简而言之，它们没有用。它们所做的实际上是增强了你对自已解读他人能力的信心。它们可以减少我们之前谈到的那种自我中心偏差。但它们并没有提高准确性，因为它们实际上并没有提供任何你可以用来做出判断的信息。在某些情况下，它们甚至会适得其反。所以，如果你与一个不同种族、不同文化的人互动，而我让你进行换位思考，这可能会让你感到非常焦虑
and uncomfortable. Are they going to think I'm prejudiced or racist or uncomfortable around them? It actually leads you to be even more egocentric and in your head than if I hadn't given you that manipulation at all. So here we are again with another intuitively interesting potential manipulation that just simply doesn't work and often actually leads people to be less accurate. I mean, that's kind of astonishing, isn't it, that we still hear the admonishment
和不舒服。他们会觉得我有偏见、种族歧视还是对他们感到不舒服？这实际上会让你比我根本没有给你这种暗示时更加自我中心，更加陷入自己的思维中。所以我们又回到了另一个直观上有趣的潜在操纵方法，它根本不管用，而且往往实际上导致人们的准确性降低。我的意思是，这有点令人惊奇，不是吗？我们仍然听到这样的劝告
to take other people's perspectives as the cure to mistreating their minds? I mean, that advice, I think, is still pretty widespread. It's very widespread. You hear it from everything from romantic relationships to improving workplace relationships and intergroup contact, but it does nothing for accuracy. In a third approach to try and boost people's accuracy in terms of their attributions, you offer study subjects, alternative explanations for the behavior of their conversation partner. So this was the idea that if you give people benign explanations for
把换位思考当作治疗误解他人内心的良药？我的意思是，我认为这种建议仍然相当普遍。它非常普遍。你从方方面面都能听到，从恋爱关系到改善职场关系以及群体间接触，但它对提高准确性毫无帮助。在第三种尝试提高人们在归因方面准确性的方法中，你为研究对象提供了关于对话伙伴行为的另一种解释。这个想法是，如果你给人们对
other people's behavior, that will allow people to settle into the interaction, make fewer mind-reading errors, generally get along better. Was your hope born out? It was not. This was one of the more frustrating academic experiences I had. I woke up in the middle of the night and I thought I had this brilliant idea, which was this. We know that anxiety can be very disruptive to interracial interactions. And one of the reasons why is when we're interacting with someone who comes across as anxious, we think it's because they don't like us because of our race. So therefore, the solution might be, well, let's just fix that part.
他人行为的良性解释，这将使人们能够适应互动，减少读心错误，总体上相处得更好。你的期望实现了吗？并没有。这是我经历过的比较令人沮丧的学术经历之一。我在半夜醒来，觉得自已有了这个绝妙的主意，也就是这个。我们知道焦虑会对跨种族互动产生很大的干扰。原因之一是，当我们与一个表现得焦虑的人互动时，我们认为这是因为我们的种族而导致他们不喜欢我们。因此，解决方法可能是，好吧，让我们解决这一部分。
Let's give them an attribution for anxiety that has nothing to do with race. So what we did was we brought people in and we told them that their partner was a little bit jittery because they had a couple cups of coffee too much that day and that can actually lead them to appear anxious and uncomfortable. They then interacted with someone who was the same race or a different race than them and we are convinced that this information and interracial interaction would lead people to be more engaged and more accurate and mind reading and all of these things. And when I came to analyze the data,
让我们给他们一个与种族无关的焦虑归因。所以我们做的是把人们请来，告诉他们他们的伴侣有点紧张，因为他们那天多喝了几杯咖啡，这实际上会导致他们显得焦虑和不安。然后他们与一个与他们同种族或不同种族的人互动，我们坚信这些信息和跨种族互动会引导人们更加投入，在读心方面更准确，诸如此类。当我来分析数据时，
I got this huge effect. It was one of the biggest effects I've ever gotten in the opposite direction. So it actually made things much worse. The minute we told them anxiety was at play, that's all they could think about. And they actually ended up seeing anxiety in their partner that wasn't even there.
我得到了一个巨大的效应。这是我得到的朝相反方向发展的最大效应之一。所以它实际上把事情弄得更糟了。我们一告诉他们焦虑在起作用，这就是他们能想到的全部。他们最终甚至在伴侣身上看到了原本根本不存在的焦虑。
So that attribution just heightened the attention to anxious related cues. So imagine walking into a job interview and you say to the person, I'm sorry, I'm a little bit fidgety right now, but I just had like too much coffee this morning. You might think, okay, well, that's going to make them think I'm actually comfortable. All they're thinking now is great. I'm interacting with a super anxious person and they they're only gonna attend to your anxiety-related cues into nothing else. You know, in popular culture,
所以这种归因只会加剧对焦虑相关线索的关注。所以想象一下，你走进一场求职面试，你对那个人说，对不起，我现在有点坐立不安，但我今天早上喝了太多咖啡。你可能会想，好吧，这会让他们认为我其实很舒服。他们现在脑子里想的全部都是，太棒了。我正在和一个超级焦虑的人互动，他们只会关注你与焦虑相关的线索，而忽略其他任何事情。你知道，在流行文化中，
people have long believed that there are ways to read other people's body language. Can you talk about this idea, the enduring popularity of reading people's body language to understand what's happening in their minds, and what science has found about the accuracy of this technique. You know, there's so much intuitive appeal to if I could just learn the behaviors, the cues I could figure out what's going on in people's minds.
人们长期以来一直相信有办法解读别人的肢体语言。你能谈谈这个观点吗？人们长久以来热衷于通过解读肢体语言来了解别人的内心想法，科学对这种技术的准确性有什么发现。你知道，如果我能学会这些行为、这些线索，我就能弄清楚人们脑子里在想什么，这具有巨大的直观吸引力。
And I think, sure, there are some shared cues. If I'm smiling, I'm probably happy. But by and large, I think people behave really idiosyncratically. What I look like as hungry, another person looks like as upset or angry, you know, and really just trying to learn generalized cues to read people's behaviors never really works because it's a lot like lie detection. Individuals might have tells, but there's no such thing as a shared tell what everybody does when they're lying.
而且我认为，当然，有一些共同的线索。如果我在笑，我可能很高兴。但总的来说，我认为人们的表现非常具有特异性。我看起来像饿了，另一个人看起来像沮丧或生气，你知道，真正试图去学习通用的线索来解读人们的行为从来都没有真正起作用，因为这很像测谎。个人可能会有马脚，但并不存在每个人说谎时都会有的那种共同的马脚。
And the same thing is true with human mind reading and perception and behavior. There's just no shared set of behaviors everybody does when they're feeling angry or happy or irritated and so forth. So we're really looking at a litany of failures here, Tess. If you've mentioned several different techniques to try and get people to be more accurate, have you found anything that does help us accurately get inside the minds of other people? We have. So the good news is we're not all doomed.
人类的读心、知觉和行为也是如此。当人们感到生气、高兴或恼怒时，并没有一套每个人都会表现出来的共同行为，所以我们在探讨一连串的失败，苔丝。如果你已经提到了几种试图让人变得更准确的技术，你有没有发现什么真正有助于我们准确进入他人内心的东西？我们找到了。所以好消息是我们并没有都陷入绝望。
I think, you know, social science has really been in the business of understanding how can we change the way people are thinking to improve accuracy? It's really putting the burden on the perceiver to become more accurate. But what we actually know from social science is we need to stop trying to read people and actually get the world to tell you what it thinks and feels. Don't try to read the world. And so the manipulations that work are all about clarifying the information that other people are giving to you, seeking that information out. I think Nick Eppley and his work talks about
我认为，社会科学一直在研究如何改变人们的思维方式以提高准确性？这实际上把重担压在了感知者身上，要求他们变得更准确。但我们从社会科学中真正了解的是，我们需要停止试图去解读别人，而是让世界告诉你它的想法和感受。不要试图去解读世界。因此，行之有效的干预措施都是关于澄清其他人提供给你的信息，主动去寻找这些信息。我想尼克·埃普利（Nick Eppley）在他的工作中谈到了
perspective getting, explicitly asking people, what are your thoughts and feelings? Tell me about your opinions. And this seems sort of overly obvious and intuitive, but people just simply don't do it. Instead, they focus on what's going on in their own heads, but really if you can get the world to tell you what it's thinking and feeling,
视角获取（perspective getting），明确地问别人，你的想法和感受是什么？跟我说说你的意见。这看起来有点过于显而易见和直观，但人们就是不做。相反，他们专注于自己脑子里在想什么，但实际上，如果你能让世界告诉你它在想什么和感受什么，
that's your best bet at improving your interpersonal accuracy. So you're saying the best way of figuring out what's inside someone else's mind is to ask them? That's right. And you know, it's hard. We have a lot of reasons why it's hard, but asking is really the only thing we found that truly works to improve in a personal accuracy. So, in some ways, that advice is sort of so comically obvious, but many of us don't realize
这就是提高你人际准确性的最好方法。所以你的意思是弄清楚别人心里在想什么的最好方法就是直接问他们？没错。你知道，这很难。我们有很多理由说明这很难，但询问确实是我们发现的唯一真正能有效提高人际准确性的方法。所以，在某些情况下，这个建议听起来是如此滑稽的显而易见，但我们中的许多人并没有意识到
it's the most effective way to understand what's happening inside other people's heads. And surely some of this is because we widely overestimate our ability to read other people's minds. We don't believe that we actually need to to ask them we can just watch you know how they're crossing their arms or we can infer from you know how they look at us in an elevator what's happening in their minds or we can deduce from how they behave in an interview what they really think of us that we are so confident about our mind reading abilities that we don't do the most obvious thing. That's right. I think you think people tend to be very confident, but unfortunately, their confidence and their ability to mind read
这是了解别人脑子里在发生什么的最有效方法。这肯定部分是因为我们大大高估了自己解读他人内心的能力。我们不相信我们实际上需要去问他们，我们可以直接观察，你知道他们是如何交叉双手的，或者我们可以从，你知道他们如何在电梯里看着我们来推断他们脑子里在想什么，或者我们可以从他们在面试中的表现推断出他们对我们的真实看法，我们对自己的读心能力如此自信，以至于我们没有做最显而易见的事情。没错。我想你认为人们往往非常自信，但不幸的是，他们对读心能力的自信
is correlated almost zero with their actual ability to mind read. They're rarely actually getting the feedback that these two things are completely misaligned. Is it possible that our overconfidence in our ability is to read other people's minds is exaggerated when it comes to people who are close to us. In other words, if I know my partner, my spouse, my parents, if I know these people very
与他们实际的读心能力之间的相关性几乎为零。他们实际上很少得到反馈，证明这两件事完全不一致。有没有可能，当我们面对与我们亲近的人时，我们对自己解读他人内心能力的过度自信会被夸大？换句话说，如果我了解我的伴侣、我的配偶、我的父母，如果我非常了解这些人，
well, it almost seems as if, well, I should know what's happening inside their minds because I'm so familiar with them. You know, one of the funnest findings, I think, in social science is how in marriages, we're actually the most accurate at the newlywed stage. And as your marriage progresses by, you know, your later years, you tend to actually just completely base your judgments of that person on yourself because you are so confident.
几乎就好像，好吧，我应该知道他们心里在想什么，因为我对他们太熟悉了。你知道，社会科学中一个最有趣的发现是，在婚姻中，我们实际上在新婚阶段最准确。随着婚姻的发展，到你晚年的时候，你往往会完全根据自己来对这个人做出判断，因为你太自信了。
And you stop paying attention. And then you end up in these conversations of like, I always thought you loved Lobster and your partners. Like, I haven't liked Lobster in 30 years. You should know that. But this is common, we're overconfident, we can get a little bit lazy as relationships progress. If the advice to ask people what they are thinking
然后你停止了关注。然后你最终会陷入这样的对话：我一直以为你喜欢龙虾，而你的伴侣却说：我30年没吃过龙虾了。你应该知道这一点。但这很常见，我们过于自信，随着关系的发展，我们可能会变得有点懒惰。如果劝告人们询问别人的想法
instead of trying to guess what they are thinking sounds comically obvious, there are some specific techniques that Tessa and others have found that are less obvious. The first is, if you want to know why someone did something or said something, don't wait for a week or a month to ask them. Yeah, I think this is a common approach a lot of us use and I think, you know, that the main issue here is that memories are fallible. We can barely even remember
而不是去猜测他们的想法听起来很滑稽的显而易见，苔丝和其他人确实发现了一些不那么明显的具体技术。首先，如果你想知道某人为什么做某事或说了某事，不要等上一周或一个月再去问他们。是的，我认为这是我们许多人常用的一种方法，而且我认为，这里的主要问题是记忆是不可靠的。我们甚至几乎记不住
what we had for lunch yesterday, let alone what we were thinking about, you know, weeks and sometimes months later. And so you're just not going to get accurate information when you're using fallible memories plus people just filling in the gaps with current information that wasn't relevant to the event of the past. Can you also talk about the difference between asking global questions and specific questions because it turns out this is another error we make when we ask people what's going on inside their minds. Yeah, I think most of us have this intuition that if we ask someone something global, we're going to get more information from them. So for instance, I could ask you, you know, do you trust me? Are you happy in this relationship? Or, you know, do you like it
昨天午饭吃了什么，更不用说几周甚至几个月后我们在想什么了。所以当你使用不可靠的记忆时，你根本无法获得准确的信息，再加上人们只是用与过去事件无关的当前信息来填补空白。你能不能也谈谈提出全局性问题和具体问题之间的区别？因为事实证明，当我们询问别人内心在发生什么时，这是我们犯的另一个错误。是的，我想我们大多数人都有这种直觉，如果我们问别人一些全局性的问题，我们会从他们那里得到更多的信息。例如，我可以问你，你知道的，你信任我吗？在这段关系里你开心吗？或者，你知道，你喜欢
when we, you know, go to movies? Or do you like it when we go to movies? Or do you like it when we order Thai food? The latter two are very specific questions. The former are very global. It's very hard for us to get accurate answers about those things. We don't even know what the person who's answering that question is basing their answer on, for instance, because it's so global, it's so kind of nebulous in general.
当我们，你知道，去看电影吗？或者你喜欢我们去看电影吗？或者你喜欢我们点泰国菜吗？后两个是非常具体的问题。前者是非常全局性的。我们很难得到关于这些事情的准确答案。我们甚至不知道回答这个问题的人他们的答案是基于什么，例如，因为它是如此全局性的，总体上是如此模糊不清。
It's very tough for us to kind of learn how to read people when we're just asking these very kind of non-specific questions. So instead of asking a question like, do you love me? Maybe it's more effective to say, tell me about the time we went on this date and you know whether, what is it about this date that you actually enjoyed? That's right. What about this date? Did you enjoy, you know, don't ask people whether you're good and bad, ask what about you in bed? They about this date that you actually enjoyed. That's right. What about this date did you enjoy? Don't ask people whether you're good and bad. Ask what about you in bed they like or dislike
当我们只是问这些非常非具体的问题时，我们很难学会如何解读人。所以与其问“你爱我吗”之类的问题，也许更有效的方法是说：“跟我讲讲我们约会的那次经历，你知道吗，这次约会有什么地方是你真正喜欢的？”没错。这次约会的什么地方？你喜欢，你知道的，不要问别人你表现得好不好，问他们在床上你有哪些地方
and what about that you're cooking. They like or dislike specifics are better. And I think if we go back to the previous finding that we tend to give people positive feedback when we're uncomfortable, the more global the feedback, the more positive it's going to be. And that, by definition, is just going to be biased towards inaccurate feedback, especially when you want, you know, even critical information from someone.
他们喜欢或不喜欢，还有你做的饭菜怎么样。他们喜欢或不喜欢，具体一点更好。我想如果我们回到之前的发现，即当我们感到不舒服时，我们倾向于给别人积极的反馈，反馈越全面，它就会越积极。根据定义，这只会偏向于不准确的反馈，尤其是当你想要，你知道的，甚至是从某人那里获得关键信息时。
Can you talk about the idea that besides asking questions of other people to elicit what's happening inside their minds, we should go to some lengths to become clearer in what's going on inside our minds. So people are trying to read us, we're often giving model signals to other people. If we want better communication all the way around, it's not just that we should get better at reading other people's minds, we should make our signals clearer so that other people can read our minds better. That's right. We often assume that we have a transparency bias.
你能谈谈这个观点吗：除了询问其他人来探究他们内心发生了什么之外，我们还应该竭尽全力让我们自己内心发生的事情变得更清晰。所以当人们试图解读我们时，我们经常向其他人发出模棱两可的信号。如果我们想要全面的更好的沟通，不仅是我们应该更好地解读别人的内心，我们还应该让我们的信号更清晰，以便其他人能更好地解读我们的内心。没错。我们经常假设我们有透明度偏差。
We assume that what's going on in our thoughts, what's going on in our emotions, our minds and so forth, is just readily apparent to people and it's not. And I've actually had to be extremely explicit in what I'm thinking and feeling. And I learned this in the classroom, in the pandemic, that if I don't tell people exactly what I'm thinking at that moment, they're not going to know they don't have access to
我们假设我们的想法中正在发生什么，我们的情绪中正在发生什么，我们的思想等等，对人们来说是显而易见的，但事实并非如此。我实际上不得不非常明确地表达我的想法和感受。我在大流行期间的课堂上学到了这一点，如果我不在那一刻准确地告诉人们我在想什么，他们就不会知道，他们无法接触到
cues. If I'll awkward at first, but I think telling people, I'm sorry, I'm not frustrated with you, I'm frustrated with my computer, or that side didn't mean I'm irritated with you, that side meant I'm a little bit tired or whatever, I think those little kinds of pieces of information, people can pick up on and learn how to read you more accurately in the future. So those are really critical to express not just to perceive in others. And I'm wondering during the pandemic when so many of us were wearing masks, whether it became even harder now to pick up on cues from other people and whether we needed to go to even greater lengths to actually clarify what was going on inside our heads. whether we needed to go to even greater lengths to actually clarify what was going on inside our heads.
线索。虽然一开始会觉得有点尴尬，但我想告诉人们，“对不起，我不是在生你的气，我是在生我电脑的气”，或者“那个叹气并不意味着我对你恼火，那个叹气意味着我有点累了”之类的话，我认为这些小的信息片段，人们可以注意到并学会在未来更准确地解读你。所以这些对于表达来说真的很关键，不仅仅是为了感知他人。我想知道在大流行期间，当我们这么多人戴着口罩时，从别人那里获取线索是否变得更加困难，以及我们是否需要付出更大的努力来真正澄清我们脑子里到底在想什么。我们是否需要付出更大的努力来真正澄清我们脑子里到底在想什么。
Absolutely, I think a lot of us lost those, nonverbal behaviors that were used to relying on. We couldn't tell if someone was smiling under there or frowning, and now that I've done this sort of explicit thing and I've taken the mask off, I'm still doing it, and I've realized there's utility to it even when those cues are available. And after the elevator, I've learned that my face doesn't reflect what I'm thinking anyway.
绝对是的，我认为我们中的许多人都失去了那些我们习惯依赖的非语言行为。我们看不出有人在底下是笑还是哭，现在我已经做了这种明确的事情并且摘下了口罩，我仍然在这样做，我意识到即使在这些线索可用的情况下，它也很有用。在电梯事件之后，我了解到我的脸无论如何都无法反映我的真实想法。
So I should always be super clear with people what I'm thinking and feeling. You know, I'm wondering, Tessa, that, you know, when I think about people who are on the autism spectrum, for example, these are people who sometimes have trouble reading the minds of others and have to learn with care and deliberation how to understand others' intentions, how to communicate their own. But as this conversation unfolded, I've really come to think that maybe all of us might benefit in some ways from some of the skills training that people who are on the autism spectrum receive. I absolutely think that's true. I think kind of what's fascinating about people who are diagnosed on the spectrum is the minute they receive that diagnosis, they're sort of told that they're not good
所以，我应该总是非常清楚地告诉别人我在想什么、感受什么。你知道，我在想，苔丝，当我想到那些处于自闭症谱系上的人时，例如，这些人有时很难揣摩他人的心思，必须小心翼翼、深思熟虑地去理解他人的意图，以及如何传达自己的意图。但随着这次对话的展开，我真的开始认为，也许我们所有人都能在某些方面受益于自闭症谱系人群所接受的一些技能培训。我绝对认为那是真的。我认为，关于那些被诊断出处于自闭症谱系上的人，最引人入胜的一点是，在他们得到诊断的那一分钟起，他们就被告知他们不善于
at giving off signals, they're not good at reading signals. And so they have to be very deliberative in expressing what they're thinking and feeling and also asking information from people. And I think because they're getting that skills training, you know, really out of a fear that they're going to get these social interactions wrong, they get much better at this and you know they're much more rehearsed with it than people who aren't diagnosed who are neurotypical even though I'm with you
释放信号，也不善于解读信号。因此，他们在表达自己的所思所想以及向他人询问信息时必须非常深思熟虑。而且我认为，正因为他们接受了这种技能培训——真的是出于害怕在社交互动中出错的担忧——他们在这方面变得好多了，而且你知道，与没有被诊断出、属于神经典型的人相比，他们对这些进行了更多的彩排，尽管我百分之百
100% I think we could actually all benefit from some of this training. I'm wondering if there are limits to this advice of trying to be explicit and trying to ask people explicitly about what's happening inside their minds. Are there situations and relationships, for example, as people are getting to know one another or in work situations where in some ways it might be inappropriate or problematic to make things too explicit? Yes. As you join a new workplace, for instance, there are norms about things you can and can't ask about. And I think there's certainly social situations where you're just simply not allowed because it's
赞同你的看法，我认为我们实际上都可以从中受益。我在想，这种试图明确表达、试图明确询问人们内心想法的建议是否存在局限性？例如，在人们刚刚认识的阶段，或者在工作场合中，在某些情况下，把事情搞得太明确是否可能是不合适的或是有问题的？是的。比如，当你进入一个新的工作场所时，有些关于你可以问和不能问的事情的规范。而且我认为，在某些社交场合中，你根本不被允许这样做，因为
non-normative to ask someone what their behavior means. I often think about this in the doctor patient interaction context where if a patient was to ask a physician, do you just not trust me? Something like that, they would get a very strange response back. So I do think there's a little bit of a learning curve for figuring out how and when to ask these kinds of questions. And I think the advice I give people is be very careful about things like over disclosure
询问某人的行为意味着什么是不符合常规的。我经常在医生与患者互动的语境中想到这一点：如果一个患者问医生“你是不是不信任我？”，诸如此类的话，他们会得到一个非常奇怪的回应。所以我确实认为，摸索如何以及何时提出这类问题是有一个学习曲线的。我认为我给人们的建议是：要非常小心，比如过度披露
or asking about people's personal lives and context for them are not appropriate. Specific feedback tends to be context-specific, it tends to not be inappropriate. So the more that you can kind of tailor the question to the moment, the less likely you are to kind of step into uncomfortable grounds. Are there situations where you think
或者打听别人的私生活，这些在当时的语境下是不合适的。具体的反馈往往具有语境特定性，它往往不是不恰当的。因此，你越是能根据当下调整问题，你就越不可能踏入让人感到不舒服的领域。你认为在某些情况下，
leaping to conclusions about people could actually be good for us? I mean, there's some research that suggests that when people have, you know, overly optimistic or positive views of their romantic partners, for example, they might end up in happier relationships than people who have more realistic perspectives of their partners. Are misattributions always a problem? The question isn't, is accuracy good or bad?
对人们妄下结论其实对我们有好处吗？我的意思是，有一些研究表明，当人们对他们的浪漫伴侣抱有过于乐观或积极的看法时，例如，他们最终可能会比那些对伴侣持有更现实看法的人拥有更幸福的关系。错误归因总是个问题吗？问题不在于准确性是好是坏，
It's what type of accuracy is good and bad and when. And I think what we actually know there is that you want to have these global positive judgments of your partner. You think your partner is really attractive and fun and interesting. We call this the rose colored glasses effect, but you want specific accuracy. So you want to be able to tell for instance that your partner is annoyed with you for not emptying the dishwasher,
而在于哪种准确性是好是坏、在什么时候。我认为我们实际上所知道的是，你希望对你的伴侣有这种整体上的积极评价。你认为你的伴侣真的很有吸引力、很有趣、很有意思。我们称之为玫瑰色眼镜效应，但你希望有具体的准确性。所以你希望能够看出，例如，你的伴侣对你没有倒洗碗机感到恼火，
or that they're too tired to go to the movie tonight. You can read those cues. So the specific things you want to be accurate about, but at a global level, you actually want to be overly biased in a positive way. You want to see them more positively than others see that person.
或者他们今晚太累了不想去看电影。你能读懂这些线索。所以你希望在具体的事情上保持准确，但在整体水平上，你实际上希望带有一种积极的偏见。你会希望以比其他人看待那个人时更积极的眼光来看待他们。
I want to return to that interaction we spoke about earlier, the one where your NYU colleague was abruptly dismissive of you and this was behavior that you initially attribute it to his feeling superior to you. You were unexpectedly thrown together when you were asked to co-teach a professional development course. How did you get along given your Rocky start, Tessa? You know, so Javon Bable, who the story is about, he and I taught a professional development course when after several years of not really interacting with
我想回到我们之前谈过的那次互动，就是你的纽约大学同事对你态度粗暴冷淡的那一次，当时你最初将这种行为归因于他觉得自己比你优越。你们在被要求共同教授一门职业发展课程时，出乎意料地被分到了一起。鉴于你们艰难的开端，你们相处得怎么样，苔丝？你知道，贾冯·巴布尔，也就是这个故事的主角，他和我在中断了几年没有真正的互动之后，共同教授了一门职业发展课程，当时我们俩都不得不在最后一分钟介入并寻找一门要教的课程。当时我想，哦，这会糟糕透了。他就是那种人。他真是一个爱向上爬的社交攀附者。但我立即意识到我错了。我对他的看法、我对他的解读是错的。他其实超级友好，超级有亲和力，
each other, we both had to kind of step in last minute and find a course to teach. And I was like, oh, this is gonna be awful. He's this guy. He's such a social climber. And I immediately realized that I was wrong. My perceptions of him, my reading of him was wrong. He was actually super friendly and super engaging. And happy to engage with me with this course. And we immediately became very close friends. But I had hung on to those wrong perceptions
而且很高兴能和我一起上这门课。我们立刻成了非常亲密的朋友。但在那个时刻之前，我一直坚持着那些错误的看法
for many years before that moment. So you teach this course together and you get along famously and often sometimes you realize that you actually like each other quite a bit and you might feel that even something might be brewing between the two of you, but your colleagues in the same department, so this is a high-risk proposition, I understand that the two of you sat down and had a heart to heart. Can you tell me about that conversation, how it went, what he said, and what you said in response?
很多年。所以你们一起教这门课，相处得极好，而且往往有时候你会意识到你们其实挺喜欢对方的，你甚至可能会觉得你们俩之间可能正在酝酿着什么，但你们是同一个系的同事，所以这是一个高风险的提议。我听说你们俩坐下来进行了一次推心置腹的交谈。能跟我讲讲那次对话吗？进展如何？他说了什么，你又是怎么回应的？
You know, one thing I really learned in this experience is when you decide to date a colleague whose office is two doors down from yours, and you both have ten years at the same institution, and you're likely to stay there forever. It behooves you to learn how to read each other accurately. And I obviously didn't have a great history with him and when it came to person perception. So we sat down together and he said, is it just me or is there something going on between us? Is there feelings between us? And I can remember seeing his handshake, he was kind of ringing his palms from the sweat and he was so
你知道，我在这次经历中真正学到的一点是，当你决定和办公室就在你门廊两步之遥的同事约会时，你们俩在同一个机构都有十年工龄，而且很可能会永远呆在那里，你就有必要学会准确地解读对方。显然，在人际知觉方面，我和他没有一段美好的历史。所以我们坐在一起，他说：“是我多心了，还是我们之间有点什么？我们之间有感觉吗？”我记得看到他在握手，他的手心因为出汗而不断揉搓，他是那么地
uncomfortable, but it was really critical for him palms from the sweat and he was so uncomfortable, but it was really critical for him to get this right and to not assume that, you know, his colleague had feelings for him that I didn't have. And so we had a very blatant conversation about explicit feelings for each other. And I think that's a funny thing to do with someone that you're working with and you're not dating to just have this very explicit, let me tell you exactly when I'm thinking in feeling conversation, over lunch and just hoping it doesn't completely blow up.
不自在，但对他来说，把这件事弄清楚至关重要，不能假设同事对他也怀有他所没有的感觉。于是我们进行了一场非常直白的关于彼此明确好感的对话。我认为和跟你工作且并非在约会的人做这件事是一件很有趣的事，就只是在吃午餐时进行这种非常明确的“让我告诉你我心里在想什么、感受什么”的对话，并且只希望它不会彻底搞砸。
And it went well, but it was anxiety provoking. I understand that you had both been married previously and you decided that you were gonna have a very candid conversation about what it meant to get into a relationship. What kinds of things did you discuss, Tessa? You know, we gave each other a list of 100 questions and we being scientists had this kind of null hypothesis testing approach
而且进展顺利，但确实很引人焦虑。据我了解，你们俩以前都结过婚，并且你们决定就进入一段关系意味着什么进行一次非常坦诚的对话。你们讨论了哪些事情，苔丝？你知道，我们给了彼此一张包含100个问题的清单，而我们作为科学家，采取了这种零假设检验的方法，
where we assumed we were not compatible and we had to prove ourselves otherwise. But, you know, we asked each other everything. Nothing was off the table. You know, what are your 401K plans? Where do you like to go on vacation? What are, you know, we both had small children. What are your 401K plans? Where do you like to go on vacation? We both had small children. What are your parenting strategies? How do you handle the following potential conflicts? What is your relationship like with your ex? How are we going to
即我们假设我们并不兼容，我们必须用事实证明对方是错的。但是，你知道，我们问了彼此所有问题。没有什么是不可以谈的。你知道，你的401K计划是什么？你喜欢去哪里度假？我们的共同点是，我们都有幼小的孩子。你的育儿策略是什么？你如何处理以下潜在冲突？你和前任的关系怎么样？我们该如何向
communicate this to colleagues? All the tough stuff, there was no stone left unturned, where we wanted to prove to ourselves that we were in the compatible before we even started dating because the stakes were so high. So you had this very detailed, I don't know if the right word is conversation or interrogation, but you had this very detailed interaction before, really, you became romantically entangled. Before we even held hands, you know, before even testing the chemistry part out, honestly. But we had to, the accuracy in center was so high. And we both were just very honest and didn't lie and didn't say the thing we thought the other person wanted to hear, because if the relationship blew up, it would have been very bad for a lot of reasons. We would have
同事传达这一点？所有艰难的事情，没有一块石头是未经翻动的，我们想在开始约会之前就向自己证明我们是兼容的，因为风险太高了。所以你们进行了这番非常详细的——我不知道用“对话”还是“审讯”这个词更合适，但在你们真正陷入浪漫纠葛之前，你们进行了非常详细的互动。甚至在我们牵手之前，老实说，甚至在测试化学反应部分之前。但我们必须这样做，因为准确性的利害关系太高了。我们俩都非常诚实，没有撒谎，也没有说那些我们认为对方想听的话，因为如果这段关系搞砸了，出于很多原因，情况会非常糟糕。我们会
been miserable at work for 30 years. I mean, in some ways, it's a testament to what you've been describing in terms of the arc of your research career, which is the value of actually being really explicit and really specific and putting your cards on the table. So what was the upshot of this very deliberate effort to have this conversation up front? How did things go? We had the conversation and now we're married. So, the upshot I think for us, aside from it being a success and our families really merging well and us being very much in love,
在工作中痛苦30年。我的意思是，从某些方面来看，这证明了你一直在描述的你的研究生涯的轨迹，也就是真正做到坦诚、明确、把底牌亮出来的价值。那么，这次煞费苦心进行开诚布公对话的最终结果是什么？情况进展得如何？我们进行了对话，现在我们结婚了。所以，对我们来说，除了它取得了成功、我们的家庭融合得很好、我们深爱着对方之外，
was that it set the stage for everything else in the relationships. So, people often don't want to be good targets. They don't want to be honest because they're afraid of what it's going to do the relationship. They want to have positive perceptions of the partner so they don't ask negative things. But we got all of that off the table from the get go and we're extremely honest with each other. And full disclosure, I talked to Jay.
最终结果是它为我们关系中的一切奠定了基础。所以，人们通常不想成为好的目标。他们不想诚实，因为他们害怕这会对关系造成什么影响。他们希望对伴侣有积极的看法，所以他们不问消极的事情。但我们从一开始就把所有这些都摆在台面上谈了，我们对彼此极其诚实。顺便说一句，我在和你讨论这个之前，
It length about this before I discussed it with you just to make sure he was comfortable. So we're always just keeping each other in the loop. And the know, the other thing I know is I'm not a great person perceiver and neither is he, but I know how to be a good target and I know how to elicit that information from other people. And I think that really has an upside in relationships. Tessa West is a psychologist at NYU. She's also the author of the book, Jerks at Work, toxic co-workers and what to do about them. Tessa, thank you so much for joining me today on Hidden Brain. Thank you so much. Hidden Brain is produced by Hidden Brain Media. Our audio production team includes
和杰详细谈过，只是为了确保他感到舒服。所以我们总是让彼此知情。而且你知道，我所知道的另一件事是，我不是一个很好的人际知觉者，他也不是，但我知道如何成为一个好的目标，我知道如何从其他人那里引出这些信息。我认为这在人际关系中确实有积极的一面。苔丝·韦斯特是纽约大学的心理学家。她也是《职场混蛋：有毒的同事及应对之道》一书的作者。苔丝，非常感谢今天来到《隐藏的大脑》。非常感谢。本节目由“隐藏的大脑”传媒制作。我们的音频制作团队包括
Bridget McCarthy, Annie Murphy-Paul, Kristen Wong, Laura Quarelle, Ryan Katz, Autumn Barnes, and Andrew Chadwick. Tara Boyle is our executive producer. I'm Hidden Brain's executive editor. For today's on-sunk hero, we turn the mic over to you, our listeners. It's a story from our show, My Ansan Hero. Today's My Ansan Hero is brought to you by Anstar. Onstar advisors are now with you everywhere, on the app, in your car, and at home. Anstar, be safe out there. Our story comes from Joe Arigoni. Joe and Joni have been married for more than 30 years.
布里奇特·麦卡锡、安妮·墨菲·保罗、克里斯滕·王、劳拉·夸雷勒、莱恩·卡茨、奥特姆·巴恩斯和安德鲁·查德威克。塔拉·博伊尔是我们的执行制片人。我是本节目的执行主编。对于今天的隐形英雄，我们将话筒交给你，我们的听众。这是一个来自我们的节目《我的隐形英雄》的故事。今天的节目由安吉星赞助。安吉星的顾问现在随时随地陪伴着你，在应用程序里、在你的车里、在家里。安吉星，出行平安。我们的故事来自乔·阿里戈尼。乔和乔妮已经结婚30多年了。
Three of their four kids are out of the house and they are always imagined spending this phase of life working and planning for retirement. But all that changed at the end of 2018 when Joni was diagnosed with early onset Alzheimer's at just 51, her condition has been devastating. And for Joe, it has tested the limits of his compassion and understanding. He remembers one morning that was especially frustrating. It was in March of 2022. Joni was insisting that she needed new shoes, even though she did not need them. So after he got tired of arguing about it with her,
他们的四个孩子中有三个已经搬出了家，他们一直想象着在这个人生阶段为退休而工作和规划。但这一切在2018年底发生了改变，当时乔妮在仅仅51岁时被诊断出患有早发性阿尔茨海默病，她的病情具有毁灭性。对于乔来说，这考验了他同情心和理解力的极限。他记得有一个早晨格外令人沮丧。那是2022年3月。乔妮坚持说她需要新鞋，尽管她根本不需要。所以在厌倦了跟她争论之后，
he agreed to take her to the shoe store. And I'm like, okay, here, here's all the shoes here. There's, you know, aisles and aisles and shoes. You know, which ones do you like? Is there a particular color or a particular brand? And I don't think she really understood. And she goes, I want to talk to an associate. And so I'm like, all right, fine,
他同意带她去鞋店。我说：“好吧，鞋都在这儿。这里有成排成排的鞋子。你知道，你喜欢哪一双？有没有特定的颜色或特定的品牌？”我觉得她并不是真的很懂。她说：“我想找个导购。”所以我想：“好吧，行，
you just go find an associate. I'm just gonna sit down over here because this whole knee that you have for shoes, I just need a break from it. So she starts wandering off and going around the store. I don't see her then for a while, and I finally hear her voice, and she's talking to the salesperson that she found. And I peek around the corner, and I see them engage in this conversation. And the sales woman, Michelle,
你自己去找导购吧。我只想在这儿坐一会儿，因为你对鞋子的这种执念，我真的需要休息一下。”于是她开始在店里闲逛。我有一会儿看不见她了，最后我听到了她的声音，她正在和她找到的销售员说话。我从拐角处探出头去，看到他们开始交谈。女销售员米歇尔
is trying to figure out what size of shoe Joni needs. She's gently helping to get the shoe off her foot and then asks her to place her foot in the little metal slide that they use to get the width in the size. And because my wife has a hard time following directions because of her illness, she puts her hand down on the measuring tool for feet. And Michelle says, that's okay. Don't worry. Why don't you just stand up and I'll put the tool
正试图弄清楚乔妮需要什么尺码的鞋。她温柔地帮乔妮脱下鞋子，然后请她把脚放在那个用来测量宽度和尺码的小金属滑轨上。因为我妻子由于生病很难遵循指令，她把手放到了测量脚的工具上。米歇尔说：“没关系。别担心。不如你站起来，我把工具
underneath and we'll measure your foot that way. And Michelle asks her, do you have some anxiety? She says, because I have some anxiety. And I also have autism. And when I heard that, it just broke my heart because here I couldn't generate the patience and the compassion. And here this was the salesperson who my expectation was that, you know, they're not
放在下面，我们这样来量你的脚。”米歇尔问她：“你是不是有点焦虑？”她说：“因为我确实有点焦虑，而且我还有自闭症。”当我听到这话时，我的心碎了，因为在这里我无法产生耐心和同情心，而这位销售员——我原本的期望是，你知道，他们
going to be able to understand Joni. They're not going to be able to engage with Joni, and I'm going to have to step in and do everything anyway. And they had just created this beautiful moment and still chokes me up a little bit. When you're a full-time caregiver, 24-7, sometimes I can take a toll on you and your level of compassion or hope can get depleted. And so you can be just desperate for some type of relief from that responsibility. And when someone who themselves already has a difficulty navigating our world is caring for your loved one with more patience and compassion than you can bustle at that moment. It's doubly impactful,
不可能理解乔妮，他们不可能与乔妮交流，无论如何我必须插手做所有的事情——却刚刚创造了这个美好的时刻，现在想起来还是让我有点哽咽。当你是一个全职照顾者，每周七天、每天24小时照顾时，有时这会对你造成沉重的打击，你的同情心或希望水平可能会耗尽。因此，你可能会极度渴望某种解脱，摆脱那种责任。当一个本身在我们的世界中导航都有困难的人，却带着比你当时能调动的更多的耐心和同情心来照顾你所爱的人时，这种影响是双倍的，
it's beyond words and it's a beautiful thing. thing. Joe Erigone of Orland Hills, Illinois. By the way, they did find Joni a pair of shoes, and Joe was able to go back into the store and tell Michelle, thank you. This segment was brought to you by OnStar. OnStar believes everyone has the right to feel safe everywhere. That's why their emergency advisors are now available to help not only in the car but wherever you are. On your phone, in your car and at home. OnStar, be safe out there.
无法用言语形容，这是一件美好的事情。来自伊利诺伊州奥兰多山的乔·阿里戈尼。顺便说一句，他们确实给乔妮找到了一双鞋，乔也得以回到店里对米歇尔说声谢谢。本节目由安吉星赞助播出。安吉星坚信每个人都有在任何地方都感到安全的权利。这就是为什么他们的紧急顾问现在不仅在车里可以提供帮助，无论你在哪里都可以：在你的手机上、在你的车里和在家里。安吉星，出行平安。
If you like this episode and would like us to produce more shows like this, please consider supporting our work. Go to support.hiddenbrain.org Again, if you would like to help support the show you love, go to support.hiddenbrain.org I'm Shankar Vedantam. See you soon. you There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
如果你喜欢本集节目，并希望我们制作更多类似的节目，请考虑支持我们的工作。请访问 support.hiddenbrain.org。再说一遍，如果你想支持你喜爱的节目，请访问 support.hiddenbrain.org。我是尚卡尔·韦丹坦。我们回头见。本集节目目前还没有评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。